[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Amy Is
With Us in Springfield Illinois hi Cami
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi hi what's up
oh nothing I am recently divorced
um Mama too and I just feel like I'm
extremely defined financially and I just
was looking for tips and advice on how I
get out of my situation that I'm in
currently
um
what what is his income your ex-husbands
um he makes about 45 an hour but I do
not take anything from him what do you
make
um I currently make 18 an hour and I'm a
personal trainer but I am only training
for like
like six to eight hours a week I think
we found your problem yeah no I know
I've been applying to jobs
um
cannot seem to find one right now yes I
know my issue is I don't have enough
income
um that's something that I'm working on
but I didn't know I don't know I just
don't know what to do are you only
applying to be a personal trainer
no I'm applying for all sorts of
different positions
um State positions City positions uh
random places you know in town I'm
applying all over the place it's just
yeah why aren't you weren't you taking
why isn't he paying child support
I was born
it doesn't matter state law says he pays
child support yeah I know I just didn't
want anything ahead of the rest of my
life and I figured that I could do it on
my own and I want to be able to do it I
know that it was probably on looking at
it now but I think that when I am
finally successful and I am out of my
position that I'm in currently when was
the divorce final
July
July how have you lived since July on
eight hours a week
um I take I take shifts at the
restaurant that I worked at
there but I'm not scheduled I just take
shifts as they come he works long hours
and we split the kids 50 50.
um but unfortunately with his work
schedule I have been the one that has
had to take the kids on the night that
he has to work late so me getting a
full-time job for the longest time was
out of the question because our
babysitter actually got shut down for a
little while
um because she wasn't properly licensed
and so yeah I have just been living on
tax return
um tips that I'm getting the problem is
the problem is is that these priorities
have gotten all backwards on you
okay
um all of these things you're throwing
at me are solved
when you tell them all to take a side
seat because you have to work
and you have money
and when you have money because you're
working now you find a different
babysitter and you're not dealing with
some jack Legg who's not even licensed
and gets put on the street and shuts
your whole operation down oh and by the
way when he calls and says he has to
work you say well I'm sorry you have the
kids I'm working
yeah
I think so you don't revolve your life
around all of these other people you set
your life up and they revolve around you
okay that's what's the problem do you
feel guilty that you filed for divorce
here
um I don't feel guilty no but I just
feel like any time that the kids are not
going to be prepared to be careful by
him I just feel like since I was a
stay-at-home mom for so long that it's
mine you're not a stay-at-home mom
anymore you made a decision to be a
career person now that's right and yeah
what you're trying to do is to have it
all at the same time with no pain that's
what I mean you filed for divorce you
left him for whatever reason you left
him
and you can't eat
right and so you're gonna have to put
your ego aside and possibly go back and
say hey I need some child support so our
babies have groceries well I'm trying to
find a job that's ego talking right now
he does have to pay me um 600 or 500 a
month for six months we're currently on
the month two of that
um I am getting State assistance through
um link and medical insurance that is
not a good long-term plan not a plan no
it is not no I do not know that plan is
you working 40 to 50 hours a week making
25 or 30 dollars an hour and you can get
back where you can eat but you have
defined good mom as being there for
everyone except making money and I'm
redefining good mom as one who goes and
makes some money to provide for her
family because she's now a single mom
redefine it
a good mom is one now that works 45 or
50 hours a week and everyone else sits
to the side while you do that they you
figure it out because you cannot be at
home with the children anymore
right you don't have that option I'm
sorry I wish you could but the decisions
have been made that is now done
and so they are the best way you can be
there for them is go make some money not
because money makes the world go around
but it does buy food lights and shoes
and you're struggling to do that right
now
right and you're scared
yeah no it's it's a little bit uh scary
but scary but I no it's on my own for
yeah I lived on my own for a little bit
while I was working full-time before the
daycare got shut down and within my
place was infested with mold so I had to
move out and I'm currently living with
my parents and
um I do sell beef
um I raise cattle on the side so I am
Cami yes you need a job sorry you need a
job I know quit explaining to me all the
reasons you don't
and working around the unlicensed
daycare and working around the husband
who ex-husband who still tells you when
to jump and you jump all of this is a re
are not good enough reasons you have got
to get back to full-time employment for
the good of your children your sanity
yeah yeah you don't have a choice and
once you decide that then the mold and
the unlicensed daycare all these other
things start to move away when you add
three thousand dollars a month to this
equation
it changes the equation because money
what it does is it gives you options
it gives you power
it's not the money itself that matters
and I'm not all about money the room's
all about money single mom called me is
all about money now I want to feed her
dad gum kids and get the stress off of
her because she's scared to death but
your your head's spinning and all you
can do is just go into this Kaleidoscope
of reasons and excuses rather than going
and doing it and you have got to go do
it girl and this is not the time Dave
it's not the season for follow your
dreams and I'm going to start the dream
job and I'll show them this is not that
time no no no no no anyone who will hire
you I got to get a job that I can make
the most money and be the most impactful
and by the way
often when families get divorced mom and
dad think the greatest thing they can do
for the kids is FaceTime let me tell you
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is a present stable non-anxious mom and
dad
and that means you got to be able to pay
your bills you got to be able to eat if
you're worried about your kids eating
while you're sitting in the floor
playing with them they're going to feel
that tension and they're going to absorb
it they're going to make it their fault
yeah you can't do that to your kids
exactly and give that to your kids yeah
we we can't you know the best thing you
can do for you and them is is go make a
little money right now you don't need to
go make 300 000 a year but you do need
to go make 50. right now right now and
there's people doing that and so
um and so uh Hang on we're gonna give
you a copy of Ken Coleman's book from
paycheck to purpose and his other book
The Proximity principle and as soon as
they hit your mailbox I want you to sit
down and read them and turn the stupid
television off
you don't need to have a TV on in your
house at all right now yeah turn it off
reading these two books and you need to
be working call local school there's
people are so desperate for teachers
right now you've been a teacher as a
trainer start thinking outside the box a
little bit but call local schools and
see if you can get in as a as a teacher
yeah anything I mean targets hiring UPS
we're coming into Christmas every retail
out there is hiring at 25 an hour right
now they can't get people and so you can
get the hours and you can get the
dollars coming in and but some of these
people are just gonna have to line up in
your life and stand to the side instead
of you being the one that stands to the
side every time that was the moral of
the story we heard when you called us
Cami so we love you and we want you to
win kiddo and understand why you're
scared but the chaos leaves when you
rise up above it and start telling
everybody where to dance instead of
being the one told when to dance